[Applause]
[Music]
happy Thursday everybody Greg is still
Greg is still out because it takes a
while to recover from a Brazilian butt
lift so you have me tonight how is
everybody doing
okay
really because everything is kind of
rough right now if you ask me I mean
sometimes the news can feel like
depressing story after depressing story
if I wanted to see that I just flipped
through my old Diaries
a former United States President being
arrested a current United States
president who can't pronounce the word
arrested deadly storms inflation
violence and that's just in the Fox and
Friends Green Room
the only thing that might be more
depressing than the news is the power
that all of this sad traumatic stuff has
to divide us
but there is a way to heal both as
individuals and with those around us and
thankfully it doesn't involve any advice
from Dr fauci
it's candid open speech and especially
comedy
deep down people do know this hell it
might even be why people tune into this
show
it's either that or the tasteful
eroticism
[Music]
looking great you're looking great the
power of speech and comedy to heal and
unite us is so desperately needed right
now that I could not be more relieved to
know that there's a book coming out
about this exact thing on April 18th
it's called you can't joke about that
why everything is funny nothing is
sacred and we're all in this together
available for pre-order wherever books
are sold
okay yeah I want to sell books right it
might not look like it but I do need to
eat
and
if you see it at your local library
steal it because then we'll have to buy
another one
I don't want to sell the books just for
the sake of myself though or even for my
husband who has plans to flee the
country if it doesn't sell well because
he won't be able to handle my meltdown
it will make sure Noble look like an
x-ray
I want to get this message out there for
all of us because we as a society have
created the wrong rules for
communication we've created unnecessary
conflict when really we should all be in
this together like that hot tub that
Banderas keeps in the back of her pickup
foreign
and that's one of the many things that
makes my book different from other books
about speech a lot of discussion about
speech focuses on how we have the right
to say whatever we want no matter how
offensive or divisive it is and that's
true
I do have the right to say Mike Baker
you work for the CIA and sometimes when
you're talking I wish someone would kill
me with a pencil
or Julie it's like you saw Snooki
drinking and said hold my beer and then
realize you already chugged your beer I
don't drink beer though or how could a
man named Buck Sexton be that boring
and Joe DeVito
not too easy
to be clear I have the right to say all
that especially because no one has been
a better sport about taking jokes on
this show than I have
he's like an earthworm small slender and
thrives in dirt and she's wise Beyond
her years it's something no one has ever
said she's like confetti after a party
people say what a mess oh and speak of
the devil and she'll appear her family's
planning a road trip to get away from
her she's on the FBI's Least Wanted list
she's like Canada
white always cold and people often
forget she's there
yeah
yeah all of
Olive can handle it
but intention matters a lot
someone who was trying to make a joke
should not be treated the same way as
someone who was trying to be mean
framing the debate as speech versus
sensitivity ignores the way that it can
unite us
especially because being truly
pro-speech includes speech about
feelings
I know this saying goes facts don't care
about your feelings but sometimes
feelings don't care about your facts
trust me it's exactly why I wasted time
dating all those losers in my 20s You
Know Who You Are
I'm just kidding they'll never see this
because they don't have enough money for
a TV
but sharing that your feelings were hurt
is not a bad thing it's good if we don't
express ourselves to each other we have
no hope of understanding each other
either it's like Biden talking to John
fetterman
even even Kamala couldn't laugh through
that
but there's a difference between sharing
hurt feelings and trying to use hurt
feelings to shut down a conversation or
get someone fired or exert some other
kind of power or control that's not over
sensitivity or even sensitivity at all
it's bullying like I do to my husband
when I need attention
which is always
the truth is when people say you can't
joke about that what they usually mean
is this is a subject that makes me sad
or angry like death illness sexism
racism homophobia or in the case of this
show anything that the audience laughs
louder at than they did at something of
Grace
but
thanks but the truth is that sad dark
horrible stuff is the most important
stuff to joke about comedy has unique
healing powers it's especially when it
comes to the scariest things in life
something else I found healing is the
realization that every tough thing you
go through you're automatically building
a connection with everyone else who's
gone through it too but what's the use
if we can't talk about it
when we give people the space to take
risks and speak freely though there are
no limits for connecting with those
around us or for what we can laugh in
the face of no matter how distressing it
is even if it's your boss calling you a
mentally deranged drunk
[Applause]
Fox News anchor Julie Banderas
he's got a voice for radio and hair for
a head and shoulders commercial co-host
of the clay Travis and Buck Sexton show
Buck Sexton
when he's not having people killed you
can see him modeling Wrangler jeans
former CIA operative and author of the
new book company rules Mike Baker
and he inspires children to abandon
their dreams comedian Joe DeVito
all right
Joe you're you I mean you're the
comedian so I'll go to you first I I
truly don't believe that there is a such
thing as something that we cannot joke
about no not at all and sometimes like
you said the things that are the most
difficult to deal with you have to say
jokes about them and and the people who
complain about that it's you have to
look at totalitarians they're not known
for their sense of humor right no one's
ever said well once you get Stalin alone
the guy's hilarious you know knock knock
who's there the KGB so yeah it's true uh
and I I it's like the saying you know
people say laughter is the best medicine
uh usually people with terrible
insurance
and yeah I think it's important I think
we need to laugh the tougher times get
the more you look for things that you
can laugh at and it's such a great
experience to share it with other people
I can think back to me being at a comedy
club and a woman coming up to me after
and saying my family's going through a
really tough time and you were able to
distract us from that for a little while
we want to thank you and I said uh hey
lady I'm trying to sell some merch here
so if you buy a CD or what
I mean Julie for me that's been the case
every tough thing I've been through I'm
I'm only able to go through it because I
can also laugh no I mean when you and I
get together and drink all we do is
laugh and all the topic is is
disparaging comments about each other
which is amazing yeah and I just think
that basically I think overall this
country has just become such a pack of
and I think people to chill out you know
like get to laugh at each other and
don't take every joke so freaking
seriously like people need to just not
be so politically correct all the time
like you actually have to be able to
laugh at everything otherwise you you
got something stuck up your you know I
agree you know what's so weird is pack
up is actually some of your merch yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like a murder of crows what yeah
what a coincidence uh Mike when you were
in the CIA and you and your CIA buddies
used to kill people did you joke about
it all the time I figured
because as Joe says some things you just
got to make fun of yeah and it helps
pass the time too when you when you do
it and sometimes we joke about it just
before we whack somebody
and uh first of all I would like to say
that Joe did not get enough of a
reaction to his uh laughter as the best
medicine line I thought that was really
good we'll clean it up and post yeah
yeah no you can't
I always thought comedy to your point
was that that was it that that's where
you you were safe and you could say
anything right because people were smart
enough to understand it was comedy and I
don't understand how because and not to
pick on younger people Buck
um but uh I don't understand how
generations of people raised on South
Park and Family Guy now can be so easily
offended it doesn't make any sense right
we all watched Cartman kill Scott
tetterman's parents and make them into a
chili that he then served him and we're
like you can't say you guys
I'll just say we had very different
experiences at the CIA the CIA that he
worked at was like Mad Men everyone's
smoking cigarettes making inappropriate
jokes very very different I come long
and it's a lot of seminars on however it
has to be politically correct and
everything else so that had already yeah
no really that had already happened so
the Mike and I had different uh
different versions or different views I
think of it from that level but just in
a broader uh context of it you guys had
better suits though for sure the dress
code got yeah the dress code got worse
um it does actually yeah
oh God
um but I also was talking on the radio
the other day about how there used to be
these movies comedies that everybody
would talk about that everybody would go
to see and that whole experience of
being in the theater with everyone
laughing together there was something
really bonding about that and you think
about some of the movie experiences you
have whether it was at home with friends
watching or you're at a theater You Know
There's Something About Mary uh Dumb and
Dumber 40 year old version all these
different movies that you know roughly
speaking you and I grew up with right um
they can't make them anymore and there's
something really lost there like you
don't really even see an attempt to make
much in the way of comedies anymore and
I do think that it's something that
really brings people together a bit like
how Sports used to be able to before
everybody was kneeling and getting
political oh I don't like well it
depends I mean Joe people something you
don't understand about comedy too is all
about swinging and missing some you you
don't know it's work until you try we
can't make people too afraid to try yeah
it's it's a weird uh you know some of
these conversations where we talk about
comedy as this big and I'm working to
sell chicken wings for the club that I'm
at I mean I'm realistic about what we're
doing as stand-up comics but it it is
this front line of what you can say and
what people will try and shut you down
for saying and it's it's really
unfortunate because the best jokes are
ones that make you laugh before you've
had a chance to think about it it plugs
into something before you can get
offended or annoyed or or have this this
boilerplate reaction and I think that's
a very good way to communicate with
people to get in there before that
filter comes through and that's what I
think we it would be sad if we miss that
because those jokes that have some kind
of Truth to them otherwise you wouldn't
laugh at them and anything that exposes
the truth I think is very important yeah
before we go you guys all should come by
my book tour it's going to be the best
time it's gonna be so weird so fun if
you miss it you'll be so mad at yourself
I'll be in Chicago on April 30th in
Washington DC on May 6th to get tickets
go to the link Tree on my bio on Twitter
or Instagram I would love to see you
there we're gonna have so much fun hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else